um hopefully it's correct
and i'd like to start out by uh
reading the uh required uh information
prior to our uh
session today as chair of division two
of the house finance committee i find
that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
the coven 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this public meeting is pertaining to
the department of education
please note that there is no fiscal
location for members of the public
to observe and listen contemporaneously
to this meeting however in accordance
with emergency order one
i confirmed that all members of the
committee
and select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom
electronic meeting platform and the
public
has access to contemporaneously listen
if necessary participate in the meeting
by the zoom
platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been available
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar
on the general court website the notice
of this meeting complies with house
rules
and rsa 91-a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting
should email lba underscore
fiscal at leg dot
state dot nh dot us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
lba staff are on the meeting assisting
us
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call vote let's
start the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance
when each member states their present
please also state whether there is
anyone
in the room with you during this meeting
which is required
under the right to no act
so representative lynn if you would call
the role please
yes thank you madam chair um
representative bucco
uh yes thank you i'm president i'm at my
home in conway and there's no one else
in the house
all right representative danielson we
know is not here
um representative heath um
good morning uh mary heath here in
manchester
and my husband is outside shoveling all
right
and i'm representative bob lynn i'm
present in my home
in windham and my wife and son are in
the house but not in the room
representative murray good morning kate
murray here in newcastle i'm alone in
the house except for the dog my husband
is off for his coal
first covet shot and we'll be back
shortly so then he'll be back in the
basement
representative
oh petrie joe you need to unmute yeah i
know i just i just uh
i was doing some i had a phone call it
always happens right at the time you're
supposed to have a meeting
yeah so i am here we got a dog
and a wife that's roaming around
very much thank you and representative
umberger
yes i i'm still in kearsarge
and my husband is out shoveling and
as soon as he finishes he'll be back in
the house
wandering around so i see that
uh commissioner blue and
tammy valencord are both with us
and so i'd like to um
welcome you to division two i know you
have been through this drill several
times
and we're uh we're happy to have you
um
i would like to know uh commissioner
if you would prefer us to hold our
questions until you finish your briefing
or if you would prefer that we
ask questions as they occur
so i will defer to you and whatever
you're most comfortable with i'm happy
to respond to questions at any point
during the presentation so really that's
uh representative however you want to
run the meeting
okay well then what we'll do is as we're
going through the various topics
we will raise our hand and
see what happens thank you
if you would please go ahead so i have
um some slides that we had shared and i
don't know if we want to
put those up on the screen or if
everybody has those available to them i
can just walk through those
uh there are two documents that we
shared with you one is a powerpoint
presentation relative to the budget
and then i also prepared a summary of
some of the federal
funds that we have received and thought
i would spend a little bit of time just
giving you an overview of those federal
funds that we have received
in response to covet so mickey i don't
know if we want to share the screen or
does everybody have a copy of the
presentation if they do i can just go
ahead and start
uh i think it would be better if you
shared the screen commissioner
you do have the capability commissioner
or if tammy would like to share a screen
that way you can go
to the next slide as you want to do it
rather than me uh
okay since i don't have the soft copy of
the presentation that was sent over i'm
going to let tammy share that or maybe
if you have it that would be great
all right hold on one sec while i go
find it
can you have it in the agenda right
i'm sorry i didn't hear you no that's
okay tammy if you have it then you can
call it up that would be great
there we go okay so tammy you can
advance one slide
when you're ready okay so just for the
committee and i i see
many familiar faces on here which i know
um
many of you understand the department of
education kind of understand
how we are structured how we're
organized um
but this will kind of level set us in
terms of some of the conversation
we have under the office of the
commissioner we have a deputy
commissioner and then we have
four divisions we have starting
on my right is the division
of educator support and higher education
um and this is the division that is
principally responsible
for activities around educator
credentialing
we currently have about 27 000
educator credentials that we manage um
through a variety of uh technology uh
platforms and stuff that we use
of those 27 000 educator credentials
that we manage
we actually have about just so that
nobody gets confused
about 14 500 credentialed educators
working in our k-12 system
so all sometimes there are people from
out of state who hold credentials there
are many people who hold credentials
that are not working in education
but just thought it was important to
create that distinction for you
another aspect of the division of
educators support in higher education
is responsibility for management of our
higher education oversight which
includes the higher education commission
as well as the council for teacher
education which are two governing bodies
that we
administer and participate in the higher
education commission
has a role um as a member of the higher
which is responsible for program
approval for
post-secondary institutions in the state
of new hampshire
and then the council for teacher
education has oversight responsibility
for
our uh rules that uh govern our educator
credentials
and so that is principally what is
managed through that division
the next division that we have is the
division of learner supports
and the division of learner supports is
one of our
larger divisions at the agency and
is really focused on what sometimes i
refer to as all things kids
and so this includes a number of
different programs so including our
title programs
so this would be title 1 or title 2
title 3
title 4a title 4b our 21c
programs that we've got going so they're
managing all of those title programs so
a significant amount of financial impact
relative to federal dollars that flow
through
that particular bureau the next
area that is also included in the
division of learner support
is our bureau of
special education and so this manages
again federally funded idea funds
principally
you have a couple of generally funded
positions in there but mostly it is
federally funded
and that is managing the special
education activities here in the state
of new hampshire
supporting all of our special educators
across the state who are delivering
services on a
daily basis the next area that i will
focus on
for you in the division of learner
supports is the bureau of student
wellness
the bureau of student wellness is
dealing with a lot of different aspects
relative to student
mental and behavioral health in our
school systems and how we might support
those students
with the belief that as we support
students in their behavior and mental
health we can get better educational
outcomes for them
and we try to make that our kind of our
focus as we work towards that
the next theory that i will highlight
for you excuse me commissioner
yeah representative heath did you have a
question
oh yes thank you madam chair and thank
you commissioner
it's very simple could you just
differentiate between
federally funded and who is um
general um budget please
i i know you have so many that are
federally funded and so few
that are are state funded thank you i'm
sorry to bother you
no problem at all so i'll try and
distinguish although what i will tell
you representative
is that really a lot of times it's kind
of a combination
so for example if i go to my idea it is
principally
federally funded but of course we have
to manage about a 30 million
pool of state funds and we're not able
to use federal funds to manage those
state funds
so we do have two individuals in that
bureau that
are state funded to be able to help
manage some of that
that activity in the bureau of
student wellness again it's principally
federally funded
through grants from the u.s department
of health and human services
or the u.s department of justice but
there are i think there are
some small amount of general funds in
there
and i could be wrong in that tammy's
welcome to jump in and correct me
anytime i get something wrong in a
budget presentation
the next uh you know bureau in the
division of learner support that i think
is important to bring your attention
is the um the bureau of adult education
and so this is has a combination of both
state and federal funds uh president p
just to kind of
highlight that for you the state
funding in the bureau of
adult education is a critical component
of matching what is often referred to as
our moe
or our maintenance of effort and so it's
a really important thing sometimes
there's a tendency to want to say like
well if we could just reduce the state
funds and let the federal funds carry
that program we have to bear in mind
that oftentimes when we receive federal
funds it comes with strings
one of those strings oftentimes is that
the state maintains a certain level of
state participation in the programming
so that we can continue to receive those
federal funds
um another aspect of the
bureau of adult education that i think
is important is the role
that it plays in the life of
high school students principally you
know
16 and 17 and 18 year old students but
sometimes even
15 year old students we attract
a large number of students from our high
schools
who are what we refer to as dually
enrolled
and so these are students who are
enrolled in their local traditional high
school
but they're taking their courses through
the adult education program
oftentimes they do that because they're
struggling
in their traditional learning
environment um and sometimes the
struggles is really just and i met with
a lot of these kids
the struggles are around uh just the
the size of the school or sometimes as
the kids would describe it to me
the drama of high school they they don't
do well with
um and they would much prefer to go to
class at you know take a three o'clock
class in the afternoon and a six o'clock
class at night
you know it fits their schedule a little
bit better maybe they've got to help
take care of a parent at home in the day
and so they are taking kind of these
night classes
they like the classes because they are
then taking classes alongside other
adults in the state
um those adults tend to be more mature
and a little bit more focused because
they're coming back for their education
and it's just an environment that many
of you many of our students in that
program find more conducive to their own
success
i only mentioned that because it is a
fairly large number
um in the neighborhood of about 1400
students
uh in new hampshire are uh you know
through that program i often tease
um and now bear in mind that that's
spread out all over the state right so
that's not in one location
but i often tease uh you know sarah
wheeler who is our bureau director
our viewer lead there um that she runs
the largest high school in new hampshire
which is obviously facetious but it's
not but
she's doing a great job with those
kiddos and we're very happy about that
commissioner excuse me uh is this what
the
eagle academy in conway falls under
or is that a different area
so um the eagle academy or in conway
would be one of the adult education
programs that we are funding i
believe it is yes um
yeah that would that would be one of
those alternative high school
options um and then we have some
just to represent so that you understand
so some of those alternative high
schools are
connected to an adult education program
and some are not right so it's not
universal that they're automatically
connected i know for people in
manchester they've got an alt high
school that's not connected to
uh the um you know the adult education
programming per se
um and then the last area in the
division of learner support that i
wanted to highlight for you
is the bureau of career and technical
education
so this is the bureau that has
responsibility for
all of our career in tech ed throughout
the state um
which is encompassed in about in 27
about
27 career and technical education
centers that we have throughout the
state
and students are either in what's
referred to as a
sending location or a receiving location
so the receiving locations are these 27
sites that have
special facilities that are designed to
be able to provide and support
the career and technical education and
then oftentimes you have
sending schools which are then sending
their students into one of those
receiving schools to be able
so those students can receive the career
in technical education
we just recently did some work around
barriers to access to cpe which i think
is an important thing for me to just
highlight for you
and what you'll find is the way that we
are architected in cte
if a student is in a receiving location
which means that their high school
has career and technical education on
site there is
a significantly higher probability that
they will take a cpe class
than if a student is in ascending high
school and the student has to be sent
to that cte center probably the number
one
barrier that we face is uh schedules
and calendars and what that means is
just the dates and times and stuff like
that
so we are working hard to help at least
those
uh you know regionally organized groups
to try and coordinate those schedules
and coordinate those challenges as much
as possible
to minimize the barriers to career and
technical education
uh it doesn't seem to make sense that
you know if you're in if
you're in a receiving location and you
have a 65 chance that you're going to
take a cte class
but if you're ascending location you
have less than 10 chance that you're
going to take
class and we know that you know probably
the kids in both places places want to
access that type of
um of education so that is our division
of learner support
commissioner excuse excuse me don't
worry at all yeah
um how many uh
children are actually being
sent to the receiving high schools do we
know
i can get that information for you we've
got a little over 9 000 maybe
you know it depends on with the cove and
a lot of numbers have been disrupted
historically we're running about 9 500
students in our cpe programs
what i don't know off the top of my head
is how many of those are coming from a
sending location versus a receiving
location
but we can get that information for you
or provide that to the committee
i i would appreciate that um
i assume that the whatever that the cte
uh committee commission
is continually working on that area
in terms of gaining access we are
continuing to try and find
ways to get further access to students i
would say that that's our number
one barrier to kids gaining access to
cpe
is uh the sending receiving model that
we have
and oftentimes like and a couple years
ago the legislature did
create a little bit more flexibility um
we used to have
a prohibition that a a receiving center
was not able to teach
academic classes to the student right so
if a student from ascending school
had to get all their academics after
sending school and not at the receiving
school
if that created barriers the legislature
did loosen that up and
allowed mathematics classes to be taught
at that receiving location
so now you have a student who's coming
to cte
and maybe the barrier was that the
math class that they needed in their
home school was being offered at the
same time as the cpe programming
so then they said well you can't take
cpe because you don't miss your math
class
but if that receiving school also has a
math class that doesn't conflict
why not let the kid just take the mass
class there while he's already at that
building
so just the more flexibility we have in
terms of the programming the easier it
is but
it gets it becomes more complicated
because then everybody's looking at the
dollars and as you know at the finance
committee the dollar is always
complicated
so um another aspect of the division of
learner support that i just want to
point out to you well actually though
as always around cte i'll just point out
as well cpe is funded primarily
federally
um to your point sorry representative um
through
the perkins grants and uh we do have a
um some a smaller amount of uh
state funding in the cte operationally
um that we spend there and again it
comes with a
moe maintenance of effort requirement
with the feds
and i will point out that perkins is a
particularly onerous
grant with respect to moe in other words
like every year if you spend if i spend
i don't meet my maintenance of effort
by one dollar it's like an all or
nothing right so if i fail my moe
i will lose my eight million dollars of
uh perkins funding that i might receive
otherwise um and then the other thing
i'll point out about the division of
learner support
so uh we have been without
a uh a division director but we just at
the last governor council meeting
uh a new division director we finally
found somebody and we've nominated a new
division director
uh that will be coming in and that will
be really beneficial
for uh that uh division as well as for
me
who is doing double duty as also the
division director for the division of
learner support which is a big
division so we're excited to have
another person on board and joining us
uh the next area that i will point you
to is the division of
educator education analytics and
resources
and this is run by a woman who many of
you know probably on the phone here but
uh caitlyn davis is the division
director for this division
yeah they're very getting a thumbs up
for caitlyn and
what i will tell you is in there they're
focused principally
on all of our data our reporting
and our compliance those are the
activities that they are principally
focused on
and what i would encourage each of you
to do if you've not
been to the department of education's
website
if you go there and then you scroll down
to the bottom you'll see a link to
something called
i platform and the i platform is a data
system
that the department has uh we have tons
of information
tons of data and through
i report and i explore you can access
almost everything that you'd ever want
to know about education
um you know we receive frequent right to
know requests
um and it is nice to have i platform we
launched that platform i think about
two and a half maybe three years ago and
now we basically just point people to
our website because they can get almost
every piece of information that they may
have been looking for
previously um and but it's it's fun to
explore you've got lots of information
um it's easy to navigate using modern
technology
and you'll be able to work through that
the other two important aspects of that
division that i want to kind of in
addition to the data that i want to
focus in on is really some of the
compliance and the monitoring
we have two different types of uh
monitoring that take place in there
one is our fiscal monitoring the
gentleman tim carney who runs that
and we've been doing that now for a
couple of years and this is
making sure that our federal grant
recipients
and our you know schools
who are the main recipients of that are
complying with the federal regulations
around those grants that they receive so
we do actual monitoring for those
schools
uh we produce reports um i think they're
included on the website now if not
they're
going to be included relatively shortly
we're just trying to again
push more and more stuff out there um
and then there's another
compliance and accountability area that
i think is important to point out and
that is
uh through nate greene and his
bureau in that division which is really
around school accountability and it's
like how are the schools doing in terms
of their performance
uh in meeting the minimum standard that
we have for education
um that is a new activity
at the agency um in fact it's just in
its design stage
we didn't previously have funding for
that and that was disrupted for some
amount of time but we finally put that
together so that we can now
um be able to do our monitoring for the
schools and their compliance
with the minimum standards for education
and so we're excited about that
and then the last division that i will
make note of is the division of
workforce and innovation
so this is a division um we do not have
a division director
i don't think that there has been a
division director in this division for
at least
10 years um and it
um so it runs you know kind of just as
two bureaus really
and those two bureaus are and it runs
under the office of the deputy
commissioner
um but those two bureaus include uh
vocational rehabilitation as many of you
know we run the vocational
rehabilitation for the state
uh serving our uh individuals
ages 14 through through whatever age
they reach
who have disabilities to help them
secure
employment and that is
one of the activities that we have here
and then the other activity that we have
and you'll see this in our budget
request this year relative to physicians
is we run the social security disability
administration so we basically
are the federal government the federal
social security administration
outsources two states responsibility for
adjudication of
disability determination and appeals
process around disability determinations
um and so we have an organization
that does nothing but that work right
now
and uh and that is part of this division
of workforce
and innovation so um that's pretty much
an
overview of the agency and while those
are kind of the
functional things i'm seeing who did
this uh
you know organization chart but where
are you uh but then we also have
our uh office of business management omb
opposite ovm or yeah opm office
management
um which is run and headed up by kenny
vallencourt who is on the call and is
our chief financial officer
um and tammy has an organization that is
responsible for
all of the budgetary the finance and
really kind of uh
finance intellect intellectual intellect
what am i saying here business analytics
sorry um
relative to a lot of the the work that
we do here at the department
um and so she is also there it also
houses our
human resources function and then as you
know one of the other things that you
don't see on here that you might
typically see it we don't have an
information technology department
because
that is run by doit and so that's the
department and i will pause there i
realize that i've given you kind of a
of a big overview there but let me pause
and just see if there's any questions
for some of the members who maybe were
not as familiar with the
agency uh representative heath you had a
question
yes please um thank you uh commissioner
um bulk rehab had a lot of issues during
the last budget cycle
and i know that there's been an audit i
haven't read it all yet
but could you just speak to is that all
been cleaned up and
and there's not a problem anymore so
what you're referring to is
um in december of 17 we put in some
financial controls and we discovered
that
the bureau was overspending um and we
ended up in an
order of selection so we have moved out
of the order of selection
uh representative i would not say that
we're out of the woods there are a
number of internal control deficiencies
that need to be corrected over there
and quite frankly it's outside of the
sweet spot of a lot of the people there
so it is not
an easy task for them to make some of
the changes that need to be made
but we did just have that audit report
it's
pointed out a number of areas that need
to be corrected and we are in the
process of now
we were correcting them before and we're
continuing to correct those deficiencies
so worth keeping an eye on thank you
commissioner and i just want to say
i'm i'm very pleased to see how well
automated you have created so many of
those areas that were long overdue
in getting into a digital form so i
thank you for that
representative lynn you have a question
yes uh
thank you uh madam chair uh commissioner
i'm i was
um i uh have to say i was i was
surprised when i heard you
say that um d.o.e is
is uh i guess the right word would be a
delegatee
from the social security administration
to make disability determinations
and i guess my question is um
do you do that generally even for
you know like in other words if let's
suppose there's a 55 year old man or
woman who who is claiming uh
that they're disabled do you do those
determinations for them or is it only of
certain people of a younger age
that's my first question and my second
question is does the
does the federal social security
administration reimburse the state
for your services yes so
uh i'll i'll go in reverse order so yes
they it's fully that and i didn't answer
that question sorry about
repeats i didn't answer that that is a
100 federally funded
there are no general funds in there uh
so basically they pay us for
all of the costs and it's pure pass
through associated with that including
you know our our uh overhead rate that
we what we pass through there as well
um and the work that we do so
bear in mind that the uh social security
administration itself
has social security offices they're
meeting with clients
so ours is really a behind the scenes
activity
where we have an office of people who
are receiving
medical records and files and really
making adjudications
principally on appeals so somebody gets
a determination from the social security
administration that says you don't
qualify and they appeal that
that might get referred to our team uh i
think we have
you know a number of doctors on contract
that we work with
uh that are looking at those and just
making determination so we are really
just a back office operation
for the social security administration
why it's located in the department of
education i'm not sure when i first
arrived here i
do have the same kind of curious
question like how does that have to do
with education
um and you know apparently this is
an arrangement that you know dates back
at the federal level for some amount of
time
through the doe and that's why it's here
i guess
thank you very much
so with that i'm going to go to my next
slide excuse me just second
are there are there any other questions
from
anyone on the organization
and what each of the
various divisions do
okay seeing none go ahead commissioner
okay a little bit to the next slide and
this is
um you know i don't know how all of the
other agencies necessarily put together
the budgets i know you guys all have
your budget books
but this document
i think is helpful because it puts it
all in one place and just makes it
really easy to kind of understand and
see
kind of what's happening on an annual
basis relative to
um you know education the funds that are
coming in
and the funds that are going out so that
you get to see it
i have it organized first through
general funds and then you'll see past
which
includes you know our general fund
stated our general funds passed through
the general fund salary
and then we have the education trust
fund as well that you'll see there
and then what you'll see is i don't know
if i'm able to circle this
you have the revenue at the top so we
are funded through general funds
um and these are the general funds that
really focus on
what we spend at the department level
in order to support services and i'll
describe
each of those in detail for you the next
thing you see is the federal funding
that we have to support education
about 223 million 255
million there are some additional funds
this year that you will see coming in
and i'll explain those separately
uh you then have the education trust
fund which is contributing
as well as some other funds which could
be whether that's credentialing funds or
other types of fees that will come in
um and those are the revenues that we
receive
and then and then you'll see there's
another line item there we don't have it
for 21 because it's not been put in
but it's just the local education
spending but again just trying to give
you kind of a big picture
perspective of what does it look like
and this is almost a p
l for education in new hampshire and
hopefully you have this document
um and then i've also just included for
everyone
some basic enrollment information and
the state per pupil cost
you know which is a computed number
based on a formula
and then what you'll see on the next
line down if you see total general funds
um you know so our budget last year was
25 and 27. there's a specific project in
that jump in there that you'll see
coming out this time and then the in the
governor's recommended budget is
23 452 which represents
the target that the governor gave us
to be able to uh manage the budget so
uh the way for those of you knew in the
process uh we received a budget target
from the governor and then we try to put
together a budget based on what that
target is and how we might deliver on
that budget
and so just walking through some of the
programs that we have
and highlighting a couple of things um
you know the first one i think you'll
see is so here's our our state aid
general and you'll see the different
components that make this up but
um the the things i kind of wanted to
point out here
is you'll see we had a dropout
prevention program that was started a
number of
years ago under governor lynch
and it was grants that were made to
districts to
respond to what at the time about 10 or
12 years ago
was some relatively significant dropout
issues in our school system
um i think about you know as we were
going through and trying to prioritize
our budget
and looking at the various programs in
terms of
what uh you know we you know where we
were with those programs and what might
go forward
um new hampshire uh has
has significantly addressed its dropout
prevention
in the state we are one of the top
states in terms of
graduation rates for our students we
have done things both at the legislature
as well as the local school district and
at the department
to minimize the effect of dropout
program
you know some of which is not the least
of which is you know our adult education
programs that we talked about earlier in
terms of the organization to try and
create pathways for these students
so that they don't drop out we find an
educational pathway that they can plug
into and we can get them through and
across the goal line of a high school
diploma
so as we prioritize so this is one of
the items that came
out of our budget and that's what i'm
pointing that out to you here
and again so it's been about around for
about 10 years
one might argue that it has done its job
in terms of
improvements relative to the performance
there
some of the other these are some
relatively minor things that we took out
but in our career and technical student
organizations
so in our different programs whether
that's the automotive program or the
agriculture programs where the
uh the machining program uh we've got
different clubs and sports
they're kind of like sports but they're
little clubs that kids organize around
for
their different cte programming and we
have always provided
support to those and we will continue to
provide support
uh but we may not get to have pepperoni
on the pizza this year
um if we have to reduce the spending
and those so that's one area that we've
looked at um
you know excuse me excuse me
commissioner
if i'm looking at this correctly uh
you did not fund tuition and
transportation
is that the cte program or is that
something else
so let me clarify for you that so what
you're pointing out is
and i guess you can't see my screen but
the two lines above that
7.4 million and the 33 million that
had had amounts in 2019 in fiscal 19 and
timmy if you have your mouse and you can
circle the numbers as i'm talking about
that might help
everybody so in 2019 we had um
you'll see the 33 million
building aid and then you had tuition
and transportation for
7.4 million those items
in the last budget were moved out of the
operating budget and into the education
trust fund
so that's why you see nothing after that
it doesn't mean that we haven't done
building aid it's just that they changed
the legislature last time changed the
accounting for those and moved them down
below
so you're gonna see those then down
okay thank you i didn't realize that i
appreciate it
yep um so they came to the trust fund
some other areas that i just want to
highlight that in terms of programming
as well as we were working to
manage this is that the national
the new hampshire scholars program which
we have funded in our last budget cycle
is not funded in this budget cycle the
dual inconcurrence
is which was funded in the last budget
cycle is not funded and i'm going to
pause for a minute i'll talk about that
in a moment and then also the robotics
that we funded in the last budget cycle
didn't fund in this budget cycle
and i think it's important to bear in
mind that some of these so for example
the with the pandemic we didn't spend
much of that
uh second year of uh robotics anyways
um much of the programming there was
disrupted
in the budgeting process relative to the
dual and concurrent
so the way that this program works is
this is dual and concurrent
fees that are paid for students who are
taking classes in their high school
and then if those students want to
receive
a community college credit for it
then they the student can apply for
and get college credit and the
department of education will pay 200
up to well i think a minimum of 250 to
the community college so that those
students will receive credit
so a couple of aspects of this program
in the budget process that i think are
important to consider
one is it didn't really make sense
for me to be the processor of those
funds
uh in effect these are students who are
taking and earning college credits so
there was not really a need for me to
administer
because essentially what was happening
is i would get a bill from the community
college and i would send them the money
and so we're like well why would you
send us the money like for me to send it
to them
why not just fund it directly to the
community college to offer that
again an administrative efficiency in
that process
and then the second aspect of this that
i think is important to consider
is you know what is you know the
community college
is already is offering these these
courses
but just to describe so we have the
running start courses
so a running start course is taught at
the high school
by a high school teacher and so
essentially you have one of my high
school classes is taking place
i got a high school teacher who's going
to teach the class whether or not
running start takes place
and they're teaching the kids who are
there it's only if the kid want if the
student wants to claim credit for that
that the community college gets involved
and their involvement
and i may be understanding this so you
may want to check with them as well as
they
have a perspective on this um but
they're
assuring that the teacher my high school
teacher who's teaching the class
has the credentials generally a terminal
degree in that subject
to be a terminal master's degree in that
subject to be able to teach it for
college credit
so for example if i'm teaching a math
class
and the teacher there has a bachelor's
degree
in mathematics and they're teaching that
math class
they're not eligible to
to earn high school credit in that class
because
that teacher isn't qualified at the
collegiate level at the post-secondary
level to teach that class
if that teacher however has a terminal
master's degree in mathematics
then they are eligible to teach the
class both for high school as well as
for college credit
and therefore it enables those students
to both earn
high school credit and college credit on
a go-forward basis
um and so the question becomes when the
when the community college is awarding
those credits
you know what is the cost of awarding
those credits to the college
so something that we can look carefully
at as we're working with a skinny down
budget here
um and then the other program that the
community college offers is the dual
uh which is basically allows students in
high school to take classes
at the community college so those
students are going to community college
and getting those
and so they are also reimbursed through
this program for those
students and so again um
you know the thinking is that this is
probably more of a community college
program than it is a department of
education program
since really we are simply the conduit i
receive the money from the legislature
and then when i get an invoice from the
um
the uh the community college i send the
money over to them
it might be easier to just fund directly
to the community college
i will tell you that there is a problem
in fiscal 21 relative to this in that
uh the community college has used up
all of the funding so this funding has
been 100 basically exhausted
in this budget cycle and so we don't
have appropriation
and i don't know that they do have
appropriation so it's something that we
can work through in terms of deciding
how we want to manage this program on a
go-forward basis because we
certainly want to make sure that our
students have the opportunity to earn
those
uh you know post-secondary credits
through that high school experience
and i think that there's some ways to do
that um i see a number of hands going
out so i'm going to just pause and
without a conversation i get it okay
representative bucco uh
you had a question yes thank you madam
chair thank you commissioner for
presenting today and and uh
thank you to uh tammy and caitlyn for
supporting this call
um you when when you were talking about
um
transportation you mentioned that it had
been transferred
into the education trust fund and then
in the budget
the education trust fund on page 1293
is itemized as building aid adequate
education aid
tuition and transportation aid charter
school tuition and
special education aid and then on the
next page that's all
uh that's all bundled onto other so
which one of those things are new and is
that that other
is itemized all those things are now in
the education trust fund
right so representative what i'll do is
i'll stick with this spreadsheet and
then i'll have tammy get the actual
reference on the page
but if you look further down and maybe i
should have just done this if you take
the 20 column
if you go down towards the bottom of the
page you'll see we have the category
called
education trust fund and then we
enumerate
all of the item there and so what you'll
see is
that if you look at building aid for
example it's at 38 million 500 000 right
so there was nothing last year but now
you have the 38
538 million 500 000 in there if you look
at the line
under tuition and transportation you had
zero in fiscal year 19
and you have 9 million in fiscal 20 9
million and 21
9 million and 22 and 9 million and 23.
so that is where those funds have been
transferred to
is that i don't that helps everybody to
see how we just took them out of those
two line items up above and we moved
them down below
yes uh thank you i didn't see that
earlier thank you
no problem okay
were you finished tom yes yes thank you
okay sorry representative heath
thank you madam chair um we did i
remember clearly we did that last year
because um
we had an excess in the trust
and it just seemed more appropriate for
those funds to be
there and i think it makes a lot of
sense i am really upset
about dual enrollment that 7 000
students
in new hampshire that participate in the
dual enrollment program
um that's something that i hope
this committee will think about um
adding back in um commissioner would you
be
adverse to that no i don't
have any problems supporting it the two
things that i would tell you is
it's probably more efficient if we just
fund the activity at the community
college right
and then and then instead of paying
maybe a fee
because if you think about it i think
what we have to think about this
representative heath is
like so what is the correlation between
between 250
a student and a kid getting the college
credit really what we have to figure out
what does it cost the community college
to administer
a program to qualify the high school
teachers so that they're eligible to
teach
you know what is the incremental cost to
the community college when you stick an
extra kid in a class right
they got you know 18 kids in a class and
then a high school kid shows that makes
it 19.
is it 250 or what is it so it just seems
to me
that the appropriate place to make sure
that we create these seamless systems
for those kids
might be better at the community college
thank you commissioner my other question
is about the state scholar program for
years we've really encouraged
people um our high school juniors and
seniors
to look at taking those really rigorous
courses and
and to be um noted for their achievement
in them
um can you just talk to me about why
that disappeared
yeah it was so you know as well that i
have been an advocate for the new
hampshire scholar since i got here i
love
setting a high bar for kids and letting
them get there um i didn't get it i
think in the last budget cycle i got
funding for it in this budget cycle and
as you know scott powers was
administering that for us
that got disrupted during the pandemic
um you know but in terms of so it is a
program
that is fairly mature has good
governance in the sense that it has a
good board of directors that's
overseeing it
and so maybe a little bit not like the
dropout prevention program that
has done its work you know unfortunately
uh
you know new hampshire scholars it feels
like it's in relative to all of the
various programming that we have
like they feel like they're in a pretty
good place right like we've got we got
now like over 5000 kids a year
who are doing this the schools
understand it
almost all of our schools are
participating in it um
so i think that you know you try to
figure out where can you have the least
disruption right and so that's really a
value that we were trying to to make
and yeah like so representative just
like me you can look down this line of
columns right we say like okay how do i
get to this number and
if i take if i put 100 000 back in here
where do i want to take it out
you know what i'm saying so that's
really what we're doing
um just one uh quick final question
um do you have just off the top of your
head a total number of general
funded positions in the doa i do in fact
let's just
do that i have it on my i don't know
it's coming up on a
slide or i'll have it i haven't even on
here or something
we can absolutely get that for you we
can do that thank you yeah so
actually can we go to oh and actually
the only other point i'm going to point
out
is so we do have fiscal year 20 i had a
4 million dollar and 4 4 million 124.21
um and then you'll see actually you know
the 4 million it goes from in 2021 it's
doit
red phone and other i go from 2.5
million
to 4.7 million and then i'm down
a significant amount and this is our
student information system
that we just couldn't sustain in the
budget and so with that i'm going to
just turn slide and talk a little bit
about the student information system
so commission yep commissioner before
you do that i have a follow-up on the
scholars program
okay go ahead okay so you are not
eliminating the scholars program but
rather what you're doing is
uh the program will continue
it's just that there won't be anything
at the at doe to support it is that
correct
exactly so we have a we work with the
nhcuc
we had a contract with them to
administer the program
and so we are not able to support an
administrator
for that program through the nhcuc
anymore but the program itself
exists there is a board of directors
they are continuing to run it
the question is should that now spin off
and perhaps you know among the hundreds
of schools that are participating in
that
maybe if everybody were to kick in a few
dollars they could support the
administration of that program which we
know is benefiting students
thank you okay okay so let me jump on
and i don't i don't want to
go over my time because i know you have
other hearings too
so the statewide information system is
something that i have been advocating
for for four years i'm gonna keep
advocating for it
uh this is really a system that allows
us
to a couple of different things improve
efficiency
we are literally spending across the
state whether it's at the department
or in the school districts man months
maybe men years of time
trying to input data into various excel
spreadsheets and various systems that
don't talk to one another
but exporting information out of one
into another
system and it's just it's an incredibly
inefficient way to do it
the second aspect is that it makes it
difficult
oftentimes i get requests for
information from the legislature
can you let me know about this or let me
know about that and we simply don't have
a statewide information system that
allows us to look across those students
and get the information that you want to
know and so
oftentimes we are reduced to you know
surveys to the districts
which again there's more manual man
months of time people trying to collect
information again
for ad hoc reports and stuff like that
and then the third
is that we have a data security risk in
our state because of
some of the disparity we have relative
to the various systems across the state
that we would be able to improve our
data privacy data security through
a statewide information system and just
to be clear
this does not mean that the state is
running the data systems for all of the
districts
as much as it means the state has a
overlay system that allows
us to gain access to the information
that we need
you know the school can shut up and keep
the information that they need
but i get to get the information that i
need so it just improves the efficiency
across the state in terms of student
information and reporting
um and so that this is one of our
prioritized needs that did not make it
into the budget but i will continue to
advocate for if you find that you have
room
and then um i just want i'm going to
flip over to the next
slide excuse me okay
representative heath has a question oh
thank you madam chair um
commissioner for the statewide student
information system
data warehouse in the past
that information was uploaded from
school districts
now are you saying that you'll have the
capacity to go in
and take the data that you need at the
local school district level
yeah so what we'll actually be able to
do is all of those
man those uploads happen manually
oftentimes what's happening is the
school district
is exporting a cvs file or an excel type
of a file from
their local system and then
uploading that to my system and then i
import that into my data warehouse
what this will do is allow us to have an
automated link so the reports that need
to come
automatically are exported from their
system to my system as opposed to going
through that multi-step
risk of error type of a process is that
a security issue
i remember my good friend neil kirk and
he might be concerned about this
so actually neil kirk would be happy
about this but what it will do is it
will
minimize the security risk because what
we can do is we can create
an actual secure transfer of that data
as opposed to now what you've got
is kind of these open files of a cvs
file or an excel file
that is then being uploaded so all of
those different transactions from one
system to another to another to another
every one of those creates a
vulnerability for that data
whereas in it with a some type of a
student information system we'd be able
to minimize that
and eliminate that risk and one more
question commissioner um
sacid has been the means by which
you get that information um
will you continue with this acid you
don't go
to a student's name or address or any of
that information do you
no all of that same data architecture
stays the same
all we do is we eliminate all of these
risky manual processes
is what we're trying to do but the sas
it still remains the primary key
indicator for the students and
i don't have any additional information
right like the information i'm getting
today is the same information i get in
this
in a student information system but i
get it through an automated process not
a manual process
so the school district madam chair if i
could
ask one more question please no problem
um so the student information is um
secure at the school district level
and you are only having access to
certain things
that you have received in the past
correct so the school district will
define like
okay here's all the information that's
ours here's the three pieces of
information that belong to the
department of education
so we will build a technology bridge so
that i get to get that information but
not the others
all right thank you uh i think we're
going to have to have a
a little longer discussion on this
area because um
i know that the school systems have
spent
a lot of money on automating
all of this information and i guess we
just need to understand
how you are going to
interact with the the various
databases that the the schools are
currently using because
it is not uniform across the state i
think as we
probably all know that's what we're
trying to do we're looking for
a system that is an overlay so i don't
care what system the school has
but i have the ability to do kind of api
bridges to be able to connect to that
data and pull up the information that we
need
so representative lynn you had a
question
uh no thank you madam sure but the the
commissioner answered it in response to
uh representative heath's question thank
you so timmy jump to the next slide
and i'm going to do three minutes left
and i can and i can run over if the
committee can
okay so here is these are our positions
we currently have 287 positions tammy
can you jump in and tell me how many of
those are
generally funded i'm going to guess it's
about 50 or 53
i don't think i have it on my life how
many
63 63 okay so 63 of those are generally
funded
we are requesting seven new positions uh
two of those will be
but they're all federally funded two of
those are the charter school grant that
you
uh that i've received and they are paid
for through that charter school grant
and then we're doing such a great job
for the social security
disability administration that they are
asking us to do more work
and want to fund an additional five
positions in that
bureau
and then i have one other just
just a moment please so
these positions are in fact already in
the budget
correct okay and out of that
the seven are all federally
funded so it's not nothing that will
have an effect on
um the general fund budget that's
correct
uh representative bucco i see that you
have a question
thank you madam chair i have a question
on the uh
charter school grant i thought it was
only
it was going to be 10 million this year
but in the budget i see where um
charter school federal grants are posted
at 27 million
so it would be it's 10 years 10 million
for this fiscal year that we're in right
now but then your budget is gonna
again looking forward to my
22-23 and so it would be 27 million
during that period of time
it would be say that again please i'm
sorry so the total grant
is 46 million yes i understand
i've gotten 10 of it
i'm going to add in this next budget
cycle 22.3
27 million and then when i get to my 24
25 budget i'll probably adding another
10.
um well the 27 million was what i was
questioning i thought that would be 10
for next year no so it's 10 this year
it's 27 million because basically i get
to
move forward with that 46 million so i'm
going to move forward
in that next biennium budget with 27
because over that full period i have to
spend all 5 million
so the initial toronto game was 10 then
i think i have
you know a 12 and a 15 trunks is the
next branches that i get from the
uh the feds relative to that grain so
we're just budgeting what the grant
what the federal grant awards to us is
what we have budgeted
okay thank you thank you i i have a
follow up on that
are you are you able to spend are you
able to um
spend that federal grant to uh improve
existing schools so
existing schools are eligible to apply
for those grants
because existing schools are eligible to
become charter schools or they can start
a charter school and we have a number of
districts who are
looking at kind of alternative academies
or some type of thing that they want to
do
and so they absolutely are able to apply
for that
would that be ex charter schools kind of
public schools that are already existing
so existing charter public schools may
also apply
for those grants as an expansion grant
or a replication grant
oh thank you representative lynn you
have a question
thank you madam chair yes my only
question was with regard
to the new positions that you indicated
um all seven would be federally funded
i i guess my only question is is this
i know that it sometimes federal
programs say okay
we're gonna fund these we're going to
fund something for a few years
and then after a few years the state's
on its own and i'm just wondering
is this that kind of federal funding so
i don't think so so the two that you
have there so the charter school grant
we know that's a discrete grant
so they've not made a long-term
commitment other than the 46 million
grant that i have we know that it runs a
fixed period of time and at the end of
that grant these two positions will go
away because i don't have
that grant funding to pay them uh
relative to the disability determination
they
have this is the second time since i've
been here that they've expanded our
mission
in terms of the scope of work that we're
providing to them
um if they were to cut back and say like
okay we're going to give you less
funding
then we would have to uh do a layoff in
that
bureau and reduce the number of
employees that we have in there
because we can only hire what we have
federal funds to pay for
go ahead and so i guess my um
my only question on that is when when
you have this kind of situation where
let's say let's take it with the for the
charter schools you have a grant
from the from the feds for a certain
period of time um
are when the people are hired to fill
those positions
are are they do they become sort of
regular state employees or are they told
look you're you know you're we're hiring
you but you're only going to work for
three years or four years and then this
grant is going to be over and you know
there's um your job is going to be
eliminated
yeah so it's actually kind of a both end
so when we
hire them we tell them that they are
what's referred to as grant funded
um and so they know that they are only
funded to the extent that the grant will
continue and that they have that
uh it's a both and in the sense that if
they
remain in state employees you might have
to correct me on this a little bit but
if they remain a state
employee for longer than a year they are
part of the collective bargaining unit
and therefore if the grant funds run out
i can't pay you for that position
but you now are a state employee that is
subject to
you know the bumping rights and
everything else in terms of where else
you might fit so it's kind of a boat
answer
but thank you very much once my grand
funds are out i'm done
thank you representative heath you had a
question
thank you madam chair i think um
representative murray was before me
though so why don't we let um uh
representative murray go first and then
i'll go
okay representative murray i'm sorry no
problem i thought mary was first but i'm
happy to go thank you both
um can you speak uh more broadly around
the
charter school grants beyond the
employee positions
what happens to the charter schools when
the grants go away
when the grant goes away does that
impact a will that create
a financial burden on um on this on the
state
right so this grant is what's referred
to as an innovation and startup grant
so the only eligible expenses are for
startup
of the charter school not for the
operations of the charter school
so from day one when a student is
enrolled in the charter school
out of your education trust fund we will
pay
state adequacy for those students so
this is designed
around the startup um i can tell you
that if you go to the department's
website there is a quite extensive
uh white paper on the long-term
financial implications of this and it
does not create a long-term burden
to the state of new hampshire
representative heath thank you madam
chair my question is with regard to
the adequacy funding for
charter schools and have you taken
into account and built in those number
projections into the amount
of uh dollars that you are asking for in
those
lines do you feel that you've adequately
covered it
we believe we have we tried to do
estimates in terms of what we think the
students will be in all of the different
categories so we do think that we've
adequately covered it
and in terms of um charter school
estimate numbers for new charity schools
what do you anticipate in the next two
years
so i don't have that number off the top
my head but i can get that information
and get it back to you
thank you
are there any further questions on this
slide
so i would like to then just turn
quickly and again i don't want to
uh overstay my welcome uh commissioner
you
are welcome to stay as long as
uh as long as we're keeping you here
how's that
okay well so then uh so timmy can you
put up the
federal covet response funds yeah so
this is something i just wanted to put
on
on your radar because there's a lot of
questions around this
um and these are the federal covet
response funds that we have received
this year so far
and well it's actually kind of a little
bit of last year and this year that i
just wanted to kind of
lay out for you so you get to see what
that looks like so so far this year
um for k12 we received about 305 million
dollars
of additional funds um i will tell you
that there is another
uh relief two other relief packages that
are being negotiated
um one is the the current in the current
administration there's another
k-12 relief package that would provide
more funds
to the schools as well we don't have
that yet but i just put that out there
so it's not included in here
so the first launch that we received was
sr1 was 37 million dollars
most of this money um is what's referred
to as pass-through money
so we receive it and then we pass
through our grant management system to
the schools to be able to deploy
it's eligible for a lot of different um
you know activities as we've described
in here
so those sr1 grants were made available
to the schools last may
um so far this year we've used about six
million dollars
of those of those funds so the schools
are continuing to work through those
funds
um and then if you just roll up a little
bit tammy
the next crunch that we received was sr2
sr2 received about 156 million dollars
and this was able to be used
almost identically as esser won in terms
of
you know helping the schools to
basically respond
to the coven um they did add a couple of
things they
emphasized in the grants award
notification
uh an emphasis on student learning loss
school facility repairs
that would help relative to viral
transmission
including you know air quality systems
and stuff like that in the schools that
schools are this is an eligible use for
these funds
and then there's a catch-all at the end
of this in terms of eligibility just
says
other activities that are necessary to
maintain the operation so
a fairly broad uh you know category of
expenses but
um those funds we've allocated out to
the districts at this point
preliminary allocations we've not yet
set those up in the grant management
systems we're continuing to work on that
we needed to do some programming around
that
um but i will tell you that again we've
only used uh six of the 37 that has been
allocated so
uh we don't think that there's schools
that are out of funds at this point in
time
um you know that are there somehow
they're unable to access funding that
they need on a more urgent basis
um the other category is we've got the
governor's emergency education relief
fund
excuse me excuse me commissioner i'm
sorry
the um the
37 million you said that only
six of that has been used uh so far
they've only drawn down drawn down six
million out there
and how did the schools apply for that
or did you
send it out yep so the way that it works
is so we did allocations to the schools
um and then we in our grant management
system we set up a
budgeting template all of the schools at
this point
have completed a budget for
their the use of their funds um and then
they are
continuing to work through that and then
what happens is they spend money on an
activity
they report that activity as complete we
validate that it's eligible
and then they are funded uh they're back
funded through an ach transaction
through
so the school spends the money first and
then they get reimbursed
correct these are all reimbursement
grants
okay and what you'll find is that
throughout the department of education
almost everything we do is a
reimbursement grant
which mary's shaking your head that's a
good thing sorry yeah
okay um
do you do you have a list
uh for what the schools were
um authorized and which ones have
knocked
or which one
which ones are not spending the money
because i i hear
i hear all the time that we're not
doing enough and i just want to try to
solve whatever that is okay i mean i can
share with you
the information here's the grant
allocation by school and here's the
amount that they've drawn down
but bear in mind that all of the schools
have budgeted their funds
so it may be if they haven't drawn it
down that they have some plans for it in
june or something like that right
i do know for example um you know
representative heath is here in
manchester i had a conversation
they purchased a lot of technology and
they were waiting for the technology
order to come in
um and so until that came in like it
would be kind of a step and i don't know
representative keith if you know if that
came in yet or not but for a long period
of time they hadn't thrown anything down
that we were waiting for this bill from
the tech company
i don't know commissioner but um i will
check on that because that was a concern
of mine as well thank you
yeah but i mean they've all planned to
do something with it like nobody's
not budgeted it towards something
i would yeah i would still like to get
that information
all right thank you uh representative
murray you have a question yeah thank
you madam chair
uh following along that when you're
providing that information would it also
be possible to provide
examples of what some of these programs
or projects are that the schools are
doing
sure although in this vernacular i mean
these are the types of things that
they're eligible
is that helpful uh yes um i mean
i can read that i'm just curious uh more
specifically
within this broader paradigm of what's
available what schools are actually
doing
so i would tell you and i'm happy to
give you any grant that you want
but if you look at this list this pretty
much enumerates it
what you're going to find is there's
going to be a lot of invoices for masks
and cleaning supplies
you're going to find uh you know
purchases of technology
you know in manchester they made a
significant investment in technology and
i think you'll see that
in many of the other districts uh that
they've got you're gonna see
uh procurement of hot spots you're gonna
see procurements
of like there's going to be training
that they did for their
schools you're going to see extra
janitorial work that was done you'll see
extra bus
runs uh to minimize and make sure that
we had social distancing
so it really is kind of this is what's
eligible and this is the thing that you
will see
so and when we get to the second trunks
the new things that i think we'll see
is we're going to see more emphasis on
learning loss more emphasis on air
systems then i'm not sure what'll end up
in that other category but we'll
wait and see so well the
um well the grant amount and escrow 2
follow the same um
process allocation as the uh
s root one it will and we've already
given preliminary allocations and then
we're just finalizing those
um and part of the reason why it takes a
little bit of time is we have some
programming that we have to do and
um and as you know there's been some
difficulty getting pre-reduced
information
this is a grant that allocates based on
title one formulas and so we're just
making sure that we get the best
information possible to do the
allocation
thank you very much either i don't see
anything else right now
roll up a little bit yeah excuse me our
representative heath
does have a question thank you madam
chair
speaking of freedom-reduced lunch
commissioner um
in your budget um did you
consider um
looking at the amounts i believe that
you have
um but have you encouraged
the legislative body to really look at
[Music]
allowing your department to use
2020 data
versus the 21 data that will show
those serious reductions that i think we
have a couple of pieces of legislation
um i know that 263 does it
and 263 does a couple of things it it
keeps um that difference and
also this disparity but um do you have
an
input on that please sure i do so i will
tell you the number one thing that i am
encouraging people to do
is to go out and get these families
signed up um
and the reason that i'm doing that is we
have until june to be able to get those
families signed up
so our initial census was low but as we
continue
to bring students back into school we've
now got a
you know a governor's directive that
kids are in school at least two days a
week which means that those kids are
gonna be showing up we're gonna be
touching them
we have until june to get that so what i
will tell you in the governor's budget
there is funding for free and reduced
differentiated aid that has been built
into there already
you know i know that there's a number of
legislative proposals out there but that
has already been built into that
but the number one thing we can do is
try to get
uh you know the families to sign up
because it's not if even if you as a
state legislature can solve it at the
state level
it could potentially affect some of my
federal reporting as well
the federal mayor may not have the same
degree of latitude in terms of how they
want to understand that
so our best solution is to make sure
between now
and june 30th we sign up all the
families that we can get signed up
and could i just to follow up then thank
you commissioner i did not know i
thought it was going to be that one time
october won't count
you have that the the federal doe has
given you that flexibility
so i've always had that flexibility um
and but we just are continuing to
emphasize it it's just we've never run
into a circumstance where
the october count was so short and we're
like oh no now what are we gonna do
right
but we still have the ability we've
actually created a
specific kind of male flyer piece for
the schools
that kind of explains like hey it's not
just free
lunch there's all these other programs
that are tied to this to encourage them
and so again particularly with students
coming back into the buildings i think
that we have a good probability of
you know getting identifying those
families and getting them signed up
all right thank you
okay commissioner you you have more
money that you've given out
in what sense i guess not right um okay
so governors
so the gear funds or governor's
emergency education funds again this is
uh funding that the governor has that's
discretionary that
goes into the education but it is more
broadly available for broad response to
um you know the uh the coronavirus
effect
um two of the areas for example where
this has been directed so far
has been for compensatory education for
our kids who
have special needs so idea students
um and probably we'll end up with a
little bit more of that
as well as focusing on student mental
and behavioral health
and then the other one that i want to
point out to you is the ian's
7 million so that is emergency age and
non-public schools
when the 37 million dollars were
provided to us it required what's
referred to as equitable services
and that means that the local school
districts provide
support to the non-public schools in
their district
for students who need that support these
are title 1 students who need that
support
and so what they did in the second
tranche in 156 million dollar grant
they said the local school districts no
longer have to provide
equitable services but the state has to
provide equitable services
to the non-public schools and they
provided us seven million dollars to do
that
the thing that's really odd here is when
you do equitable services
i don't get to provide this as a grant
for the most part i don't provide this
as a grant
to the non-public school i have to
actually procure the services
for the non-public school so that if the
school needs chromebooks
i have to go buy chromebooks for them i
can't give them money to go buy
chromebooks
and so just to let i only share that
with you because
that is a um administratively that's
something we're having to walk through
because we're not necessarily set up to
go procure seven million dollars worth
of
uh services for all of our non-public
schools in the state but it is something
we're working with department of
administrative services and
uh and hopefully we'll be able to
execute that well
and then if you want to just scroll up
one more time tammy excuse me uh i think
you didn't have enough challenges with
uh what was going on so uh the feds
thought you could
uh handle something new but
representative heath you have a question
just thank you madam chair
just uh to follow up on um actually the
chairs
um request can we get um
yes i know that you have to do
spreadsheets for each school district
for each pot of money could you um
um allow us to get to get access to
those as well please
sure thank you you want the allocations
i can send those allocations out to you
i mean i think you know uh murray was
also looking for that as well so i'll
but she's gonna then so here's the
allocation and here's where that stands
so i'll make sure i send that out
so the next question the us department
of agriculture provided us with an
additional 47 million dollars to support
our food nutrition
in the state um as you know we're
serving many more meals
throughout the state because we've
opened up our eligibility and this just
helps us continue to support that
and then lastly through gopher uh which
is the governor's office for emergency
relief and recovery
uh we provided november supplemental
grants to the schools for 45 million
dollars
that included a every school got 200 per
student for 35 million
and then we had a 10 million dollar pot
where we had schools that had
extraordinary you know disruption they
had some project that had to get done
and they had no other funding sources
and they applied for those grant funds
and then we fully awarded those as well
so these this is just a summary so far
of the federal funds
that have come into the school if you go
back up to the top so the total of all
these is about 305 million dollars
that we have made available to the
districts to help with their response to
cobit
okay um so
this was all basically from
the cares act that was passed a year ago
this money combination of the cares
actually was passed a year ago
as well as um from the
uh the relief the caris chrisa that was
passed in december 28
is 156 million come to us from that and
then
48 million dollars was just an
appropriation from the u.s department of
education
not a separate congressional act
okay so um
we're not expecting any additional money
then from the uh december
passage of that
so this is the money that from that bill
that is directed to the
school system you know i don't know what
the funds are that will be directed to
the state and how that will be
distributed within the state so i can't
comment on that
we do anticipate if the current
relief legislation is passed that's in
congress now
that additional funds will be made
available to the district
okay uh i would like to say that i
contacted
the superintendent of schools here in
conway
and they have tried
every which way they could
to get the parents to sign the children
up for uh the free and reduced lunch
and they are having like zero
success in doing that and so
i i know that
you know kevin said i send text messages
i do phone calls i send
emails i send the forms home
with the kids and we're just not
we're just not making any progress in
that area
and you know i don't know
what other school systems are doing but
i
i certainly believe in our sau
that they have tried everything possible
to get the families to to sign up
and i i know that you know
everyone right now is eligible for
lunch and so it becomes a
uh a really tough situation
to change the um to get
to get the families to sign up so i have
if you have some sort of a brilliant
idea
about what what the
superintendents can do uh would you let
us know
because they have in at least in sau9
from uh what he explained to me i don't
know what else he could do
it's the only other strategy that i have
continued to hear is um
you know going to where the meals are
being distributed because we still
do have some meals that are being
distributed to families doing pickups at
centralized locations
so when those parents come to pick up
the meal have them fill out the form for
the meal
okay good and then i have districts that
are going door to door
um i have i do have one lea that has
gotten
all of them in right and but they
literally had to
go to the families and say we need you
to fill this out and then they were able
to get them
but i i will reiterate that in the
current budget proposal we do have the
free reduced differentiated aid
built into that budget
you know so as this thing evolves we'll
be able to see what that looks like
okay are there uh are there any further
questions
i'm sorry representative heath thank you
madam chair i i just want to concur with
with our chair
this is a very very difficult time for
school districts and families
and any help that the department of ed
can provide
um it's just i don't even know where to
begin with all the issues that have
come up and my biggest worry are those
children who have simply
disappeared and nobody can reach them
nobody can find them
um so it's it's a hard time and it
certainly is a situation that we've had
a lot of
discussions in our children's caucus
about thank you commissioner
but i do have a couple of other
questions i i didn't know
madam chair are you wrapping up uh
no if you have other questions please
yeah i i will excuse me just a second i
mickey do i have education scheduled for
thursday of next week
i think that's the day so um
we will have uh uh a deeper dive
into uh into what's going on there
so i as so we'll
we'll have some other things but please
if you know if you have questions
i'd like you to uh please ask them at
this time
all right thank you i just have two
quick ones um one question and i think i
saw it in the budget
and i was very excited about seeing it
and i'm hoping i'm correct in my
assumption
is the national teacher accreditation
program
and i thought i saw five thousand
dollars in each year of the biennium for
that
am i correct um so i believe i believe
that's a membership
okay um and my second question
is with regard to teacher credentialing
and my question to you is how
much funding do you have in reserve
in that um well not in the budget itself
but in the department how much money do
you have in reserve
so i don't know the exact amount but i
do know that what we did is we just
this last year we reduced our uh renewal
fees
so uh essentially because i saw there
was some reserve that was developing
and so we're just going to return that
back out to our credential holders by a
reduced fee is what we're doing
because i know you're self-funded
through that that program
that that department um but if you could
that's
really that i think it's important like
so the philosophy we have is like we
should not be accumulating money there
right the fees are supposed to pay for
the credentials and if we don't need
that money then we should return it to
the credentials
so that's why we reduce that just one
thought though um with
that those funds one of the areas that
um
is often lacking is professional
development
statewide for our teachers and i often
thought that that would be
a wonderful source of funding for
teachers
and educate elite educational leaders
in terms of what the state could do i
mean this goes back to my
former role that the department never
having enough money to do professional
development just a thought i thank you
for answering my questions
uh commissioner is that a 125
situation which one
the credentialing when you say 125 i'm
not sure
what you mean oh well it's uh
where you charge 125 percent of the cost
um so i don't know how they derive that
fee so we've had a fee for some amount
of time and then i saw a balance
accumulating so we did some modeling and
said
we can reduce the fee i didn't want to
go too drastic and then i ended up in
trouble
but we reduced the fee and are leading
it back off so i don't think it is
based on a fixed percent of cost plus a
percent
plus a fee because the number of
licenses that we renew varies every year
so it's really a function of just
managing that
balance in the educator fund uh what i i
mean
i think representative heath might
remember maybe represent
remember you do as well i think a couple
of years ago you guys might have come in
and swept some of that
and um i think that that's the teacher's
money and i think we're gonna get it
back for the teachers
so uh tammy you had a uh your hand
raised
i just wanted to say that it is not a
125.
thank you okay thank you thank you
uh representative lynn yes i wonder
commissioner if i could go back to the
the issue that was raised by uh
representative umberger with regard to
uh difficulty in having
parents sign up for the free and reduced
i just want to make sure that i'm
understanding
that is the if parents don't sign up
for the free and reduced lunch program
does that mean that the kids don't get
the free and reduced lunch
or is it just or do they get it anyway
and it's just sort of a paperwork issue
yeah so this is what the problem is so
we've received waivers so normally what
we have to do is we have to qualify
people
to be able to receive free lunch we've
gotten waivers
during the pandemic from the u.s
department of agriculture that allows us
to feed everybody
right so whether you fill out a form or
you're not it's free food right
and so what's happening there's no
motivation to fill out the paperwork
because you're going to get your food
whether you fill out the paperwork or
you don't fill out the paperwork
so many people are like well there's no
reason to fill it out i still get free
lunch
and so that's what's driven it the
difficulty is
is that well while you're focusing
really on the state
solution relative to that in terms of
state adequacy and the effect on state
funding
that free and reduced application is
also
the basis for many of my federal
allocations
and so if those parents don't fill them
out you might solve the state problem
but i still may have a federal problem
so that's why i say my number one goal
is like let's get the applications
filled out as best you can
can i just ask a follow-up on that
certainly
yeah so my other question is is this
i wonder if part of the problem here or
part of the issue here
is um some reluctance on the part of
parents to to kind of acknowledge
that they you know that they are in need
of the of the free and reduced lunch
program and
so i guess my question is is you know as
sort of as a practical matter if i'm a
student in one of these schools and i'm
getting free and reduced lunch
does does everybody in the school know
that i mean do the other kids know that
is that
whether they're supposed to know it or
not i'm really sort of asking a
practical question do
do they in fact know it so there are um
mechanisms in place to make sure that
that information from the system is not
shared
it's quite possible that a student might
do that but a student walking through
the lunch line nobody's gonna know
thank you uh commissioner maybe somebody
could
um forward to us the
uh title programs that are
allocated based on free and reduced
lunch
and i think that that would help
representative
lynn understand how
important the free and reduced lunch
counts are and uh so
what i'm going to do i can send this
over to you and this might be helpful
this is i mentioned the flyer so i just
like called this up
i can shrink it down a bit so you can
see it better
but this is more than a meal application
and then we go through all of
you know it's a pebt eligibility after
school academic enrichment programs
free and reduced meal 30 day rollover
from the next year state and federal
funding and school budgets funds
computer technology in your home
fee waivers for college application
resources for classroom teachers like
all of these things are affected if we
don't get these applications so this is
a flyer that we created and shared with
the schools and i'm happy to share with
you
help understand why it's important and
why
we need to get this you know these
applications done
thank you that would be great
appreciate it very much but you don't
have the actual
title programs identified there do you
no i don't i can go get the title
program for you as well yeah just
you know just hand write it on there you
don't uh
you know we don't need you to prepare
something different just
so that we know that uh you know
what what what programs are the only
question i'll tell you is that you know
as we're having a conversation at the
state level
the feds are having conversation as well
about the effect of this because it's
not unique to new hampshire
and so while i can describe those we may
or may not get some kind of relief at
the federal level
right we don't know if they provide some
kind of a waiver they say use last
year's counts or
you know and there have been
circumstances where they've given us
flexibility in terms of the accounts
that we use
it makes it very difficult for um
for the for those for the dollars that
come in for the federal program
for the schools to budget and to you
know to know but
obviously they will never turn down
money that's sent in the future so
you know hopefully we can get all of
this worked out
are there any other questions of the
commissioner at this point
representative heath i apologize madam
chair just
you don't you don't have to apologize
this is
your opportunity so please we haven't
talked
much at commissioner thank you for
taking my question
we haven't talked much about the
scholarship programs
when we i don't want you to do it now
but when we meet again
would you please just review
the steps and the differences and
what we're doing now with all of us
different scholarships
how they're working to whom they'll go
who
gets what and who doesn't get what they
use
are used to getting i would deeply
appreciate that because i've been trying
to
look at the draft of hb2 and looking at
the budget
i just can't decipher all of that and it
would be helpful
if you could walk me through that next
week so i'm happy to do that
expect i want to be careful so the
office of strategic planning is the one
who's administered most of the governor
scholarship programs
or through the university system
directly so
it might be more appropriate for them to
explain those scholarship programs
because those are not administered for
the department
all right thank you yeah they there's
um there are some changes that are being
made
to the to the scholarship programs and
uh
well yes mary somehow or other i know
i just know that mickey will be able to
find the right person
to come and talk to us about that
he always does thank you madam chair
absolutely
representative you're on youtube
representative
oh representative amber you're muted
sorry
yeah this newfangled technology but i
wanted to thank you very much
for uh coming and uh talking to us today
and i know that myself as well as the
entire committee
appreciate your uh what you're doing and
uh i know that our uh we'll be uh
taking this deep dive into the budget
and
trying to come to grips with uh
what we need to do and
we'll see what happens so and
anyhow recess representative i think
your tentative schedule had doe
on for friday of next week not thursday
so i don't know if you want to confirm
that with them while we have them
yeah i'm sorry let me look at can i i'll
be right back okay
yes i'm sorry it is next friday
at 10. we've got transportation on
wednesday
safety on thursday and
doe on friday
tammy you have a comment or question yes
just
um we have a capital buzz budget
presentation at 10 15 on friday
okay um
can we make it one o'clock
that you know what my only uh this is
bob lynn my only uh
concern is i have i have to be in
londonderry at noon to get my first
vaccine shot and uh so i'll be there
i'll be back as soon as possible but i'm
not missing that
caitlyn you have your hand raised
hello can you hear me yeah no problem oh
i was just gonna say friday morning
i don't believe i need to be a capital
budget so we could do
school aid like adequacy and building
aid in the morning if you wanted to use
that time
and then the commissioner and tammy can
do the capital budget presentation
if that works for the committee that's
fine with me if that's agreeable with
the commissioner i'm sure it is
okay uh representative murray you have
your hand raised
yes thank you um are they are we
starting at 10 o'clock on those mornings
those days uh yes we are okay i've got a
bill at nine o'clock
on wednesday so i should be totally fine
to be
here at 10. this is a great thing with
zoom i don't have to move i can just
flip from one meeting to the next that's
it's this is fabulous
yeah we can we can set up three
computers in our office
or i'm sorry in my dining room
some of us have done simultaneous
meetings on occasion this is
wow the the other quantum mechanics
being in two places at one time
the other issue representative uh we may
have on uh wednesday with dot
is i believe governor and council is
meeting in the morning so they had a
little bit of a concern with a conflict
there so
i don't know if we can maybe work
something with them that they could
provide some somebody to meet with us in
the morning or if you didn't want to
just push them to the afternoon
so we may have to work on that
okay well i need to get that to janet
um well
why don't we just make it one o'clock on
the
d.o.t right yeah on thursday i can
change that
wednesday wednesday next week
i can't even think about tomorrow and uh
yeah
wednesday so i will uh i'll
change that with janet should we plan
for the whole day
two three four should we plan for the
whole day
uh probably two and a half hours
so it really depends on
what kind of questions you know you have
with the with the various agencies
and we're looking also on monday
uh we're calling that hb1
hb2 work session
uh so mickey will be going through
all of the areas that affect us
in hb2 and hopefully we'll
hopefully we'll have the the bill
uh before then
but uh if not we'll still go through it
and make up our own hb2 as to
what what we would what we would really
like to see in hb2 as opposed to
what might be there so is that
work for you uh mickey it does and um
and we can talk about whether you want
to schedule all of these work sessions
to be somewhat generically titled so we
could
um fill some space with you know for
instance
if doe is available wednesday morning
whereas dot's not you know maybe we
have them talk about an issue or two to
use that time it's up to you we can talk
about that later as well
uh i uh okay you and i will have a
conversation but anyhow just just know
that next week is monday
wednesday thursday and friday
and it's march i know i can't believe it
saint patrick's day is coming up so
and spring
will do on st patrick's day oh i guess i
shouldn't say that
i was gonna have some green beer for
everybody but
nobody will know okay that's true
now commissioner don't you be talking
about what
you're legislating do you do
one one thing about division two as you
know is that we always have a good time
and that's uh and that's what i that's
one of the reasons i like our
division so much so okay if there's
nothing else
we will uh close down
and i will see all of you
tomorrow at uh right
at session which ought to be yeah
in person yeah yeah in real life
yeah first time i've been out of my
house in a long time except
when i went to get my shot i'll have a
chance to get caught up on wait wait
don't tell me in the car
that's true i think i'm i think i'm
still in january
okay so um thank you all for being here
and all of your
great questions that you asked today and
we'll see you on friday
when we will be talking with the
university system and the community
college
and that starts at 10 30
because the chancellor for the community
college had something going on at nine
and so we wanted to make sure that we
gave her
the appropriate time to get herself
transitioned from
whatever she was doing to our meeting so
if there's nothing else we'll recess
this meeting and
i'll see you on friday alright thank you
bye bye
oops bye